[Musique]
je vous en prie
installez-vous Nicolas Tenzer je vous
présente géopolitologue professeur à
scienceep président du Centre d'études
et de réflexion pour l'action politique
et auteur de ce livre notre guerre le
crime et l'oubli pour une pensée
stratégique c'est aux éditions de
l'Observatoire le conflit en Ukraine qui
va entrer dans sa 3è année le 4 février
ça fera 2 ans que la Russie est
intervenue en Ukraine en quoi c'est
notre guerre ben c'est notre guerre
parce que d'abord c'est une guerre
contre l'humanité et que à partir du
moment où la Russie de Poutine assassine
par centaines de milliers depuis 24 ans
des personnes qui sont des civils que je
sois d'abord en tchenie que ce soit en
geéorgie que ce soit en Syrie que ce
soit en Ukraine que ce soit dans des
pays africains ça veut dire que c'est
une atteinte à l'humanité et si on prend
sérieusement tout ce que nous avons bâti
fondé sur le plan légal sur le plan
moral après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
on peut dire qu'il y a vraiment une des
atteintes les plus graves à l'humanité
même si ce n'est pas la seule
deuxièmement parce que si Poutine devait
vaincre en Ukraine c'est-à-dire
récupérer la totalité voire même une som
une partie du territoire ukrainien ce
serait directement l'Europe qui serait
menacé c'est-à-dire que derrière il
irait plus loin il irait vers la Pologne
il irait vers les pays Bales il irait
vers la République tchèque peut-être
vers l'Allemagne et vers la France et
que en trème lieu vous avez également
des attaques directes de Poutine contre
notre
démocratie contre la France contre les
autres pays européens aussi bien sûr à
travers des réseaux d'influence
puissants à travers des agents des
Français des traîtres qui agissent pour
la Russie qui sont payés dans bien des
cas pour la Russie et qui essae de miner
en profondeur notre démocratie donc ce
n'est pas nous d'une certaine manière
bien sûr qu'il faisont la guerre à la
Russie en revanche la réalité c'est que
la Russie nous fait la guerre et que la
ripos que nous devons apporter c'est
bien évidemment notre guerre celle que
nous devons livrer vous trouvez que la
la prise de conscience là-dessus sur le
fait que c'est notre guerre est
suffisante en France et et en Europe je
pense qu'elle commence à arriver
beaucoup trop tardivement moi je fais
partie de ceux qui alertait sur la
Russie depuis plus de 15 ans elle arrive
doucement mais je trouve que nous sommes
encore en au milieu du gay euh alors je
dirais pas spécifiquement en France mais
dans l'ensemble des pays européens et
des démocraties occidentales puisque
j'incluraai dedans bien sûr les
États-Unis le Canada le Japon la Corée
du Sud qui sont les grandes démocraties
du monde euh parce que d'abord il faut
bien savoir que nous n'avons pas aidé
l'Ukraine suffisamment depuis le
début il y a une chose très simple que
je voudrais dire c'est que moi je suis
allé trois fois en Ukraine depuis le
début de la nouvelle guerre une
vingtaine de fois évidemment au total
euh chaque famille ukrainienne connaît
quelqu'un personnellement un membre de
sa famille un ami proche qui a été tué
mutilés pendant cette guerre au total ce
sont des dizaines et probablement plus
d'une centaine de milliers de personnes
qui ont été tuées je parle des civiles
mais aussi bien sûr des militaires par
la Russie et chaque fois que je vois
leur visage je me dis est-ce que nous
aurions pu les sauver et je pense qu'il
y a une forme de culpabilité que moi
personnellement je ressens mais que nous
devons ressentir collectivement c'est
pas une culpabilité directe bien sûr
dans l'acte parce que nous aurions pu
sauver c'est que si nous avions donné
des encore une fois dès le 24 février
les armes nécessaires à l'Ukraine nous
aurions d'abord sauvé des vies et je
pense qu'on n' pas encore cette
responsabilité deuxièmement pour
répondre totalement à votre question je
vois encore par le Président de la
République qui dit d'ord jeis très
heureux de cet effort supplémentaire de
la France soyons parfaitement clair mais
qui disait encore il y a peu de temps
nous ne sommes pas en guerre contre la
Russie je comprends parfaitement qu'il
ne disent pas l'inverse qu'il va pas
dire nous sommes en guerre contre la
Russie mais ça donne l'impression que
nous sommes en quelque sorte en dehors
du conflit rappelez-vous l'expression
employée par des dirigeants occidentaux
par Joe Biden par Emmanuel Macron par
ola sch par d'autres qui disent voilà
nous allons aider l'Ukraine aussi
longtemps qu'il le faudra mais sauf que
le temps d'abord il joue contre nous il
joue en faveur de Vladimir Poutine mais
le temps qui passe ce sont concrètement
des vies de femmes d'enfants d'hommes
sacrifiés donc on peut pas dire on a le
temps non il faut aller tout de suite
très vite il y a beaucoup de choses dans
ce que vous nous avez dit d'abord sur
les munitions parce que l'Ukraine a
alerté hier sur une pénurie de munition
vous l'avez dit Emmanuel Macron dans sa
conférence de presse a annoncé l'envoi
d'armes de missile il y a une coalition
artillerie qui s'est mise en place hier
est-ce que c'est suffisant est-ce que
l'effort de la France est suffisant
j'ajoute que Sébastien le des armées a
annoncé la produ de près de 80 canon
César cette année alors d'abord
effectivement cet
effort il est
louable vraiment encore une fois je je
je dis c'est très bien de faire plus il
vient quand même
après des année où nous aurions pu faire
beaucoup plus c'estàdire que lorsque
Emmanuel Macron le 13 juin 2022 au salon
eurosator grand salon de défense disait
nous devons transformer les économies
européennes en économies de guerre il
avait totalement raison la réalité c'est
qu'on n' pas vu de transformation au
cours de l'année dernière je vois des
industriels de défense je connais
quelques un assez bien euh qui disait
ben voilà nous sommes en train de
multiplier notre production c'est très
bien mais nous avons aussi des grandes
difficultés aussi pour produire parce
que ce sont des entreprises que derrière
elles doivent s'endetter qu'elles
doivent recruter elles n'avaient pas
toujours le soutien nécessaire et quand
on voit par exemple le plan de
l'Allemagne le plan de l'Allemagne même
si celle-ci ne donne pas et c'est une
monte absolu les taorus c'est-à-dire les
missiles à longue portée à l'Ukraine est
beaucoup plus important que le nôtre
malgré tout même si comme le ministre le
cornur on peut dire qu'on peut critiquer
certains chiffres qui ont été diffusés
dans le public notamment l'Institut kil
et cetera mais derrière effectivement
nous ne sommes pas encore complètement
jusqu'au bout j'espère aussi que les
mirages 2000 vont arriver si l'armée
ukrainienne le demande et je pense que
la FR ça veut dire qu'il faut envoyer
des avions parce que cette question elle
se pose toujours Emmanuel Macron pour le
moment ne dit pas oui alors il ne dit
pas oui sans dire NON NON PLUS c'està
dire qu'il y a une ambigué il y a eu des
reportages enfin des enquêtes du Figaro
l'année dernière qui montrai que quand
même que des pilotes Ukrainiens voilà
était formé donc je pense que ça c'est
très important moi je pense qu'il faut
depuis le début de la guerre je l'avais
dit dès le 24 février 2022 jeavais dit
jeavais dit en fait depuis 2014 mais il
faut aller totalement du côté des
Ukrainiens c'estàd donner aux Ukrainiens
tout tout de suite compris par l'envoie
de moyen a rien bien sûr
moi je pense qu'il faut s'engager c'est
notre guerre donc ça veut dire un
engagement aussi total moi j'étais de
ceux qui de 24 février demandait
clairement j'étais un peu seul en Europe
enfin il y en avait quand même quelques
autres qui disaent que nous devions
nous-même nous engager dans cette guerre
alors non pas avec des troupes au sol je
dis tout de suite les choses s'agit pas
d'envoyer des jeunes français allemands
américains effectivement combattre sur
le terrain avec des botte sur le terrain
bon mais en revanche que par le biais je
dirais de d'attaques aériennes ou de
contre les forces russes qui seraient
stationnées en Ukraine qui parce
qu'elles l'ont envahli ce pays malgré
tout nous aurions dû le faire dès le
début c'est parfaitement légal il y a un
article que je veux toujours citer qui
est l'article 51 de la Charte des
Nations-Unis qui dit que non seulement
un pays attaqué a le droit de se
défendre mais que également des pays qui
viendraient à son secours sont
parfaitement légitimes en droit à le
faire donc allons-y et là aujourd'hui je
trouve que les Américains c'est quand je
parlais d'irresponsabilité je trouve que
les Américains les Alliés en général ne
sont pas suffisamment fort dans le
soutien à l'Ukraine notamment par les
moyens aériens parce qu'on sait très
bien on parle de la contreoffensive
ratée du printemps ce sont pas les
Ukrainiens qui ont sont la faute comment
voulez-vous et aucune armée du monde ne
l'aurait fait lancer une condre
offensive sans être capable de frapper
dans la
profondeur les troupes ennemies et ça
pour ça il faut des avions et il faut
des missiles à longue portée j'espère
aussi dernier détail c'est un détail
technique que les scalpes nouveaux qui
seront livrés ne seront pas et
permettront d'atteindre le territoire
russe parce que c'est là qu'il faut
frapper et il faut que les Alliés disent
clairement que l'Ukraine peut frapper le
territoire russe et il faut lui en
donner les moyens sur la question de
l'Union européenne parce que ce que dit
le ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
c'est qu'on va produire 78 canons César
mais que le financement ne pourra pas se
faire totalement par la France qu'esère
ère que les autres pays de l'Union
européenne vont en financer une grande
partie et par l'annonce de cette
production qui va lancer en quelque
sorte un signal positif est-ce que vous
trouvez que le soutien financier de
l'Union européenne à l'armement est trop
faible aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il est trop faible il y a
un certain nombre de blocage que l'on
sait aussi avec le nouveau paquet qui
devait être voté qui a été bloqué par la
Hongrie là je pense qu'on va pouvoir
trouver heureusement un moyen de
contourner le le véau hongrois qui est
le cheval de TR de la Russie en Europe
on le sait parfaitement depuis longtemps
je pense qu'il faut effectivement
mutualiser beaucoup plus les moyens moi
je suis aussi très heureux de voir que
la France je soutient tout à fait cette
initiative à lancer une coalition pour
l'artigerie je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose oui bien sûr je pense qu'il
faut aller vraiment jusqu'au bout je
pense que encore une fois à partir du
moment où c'est notre guerre et on dit
que vraiment c'est une guerre qui est
existentielle d'abord pour l'Ukraine
bien sûr mais pour nous aussi nous
devons nous donner tous les moyens et je
pense qu'il faut je pense que les
Françaises et les Français sont pas du
tout idiots c'està-dire que d'abord ils
ont compris que la Russie était une
menace on voit dans les sondages qu'ils
soutiennent majoritairement l'Ukraine et
je pense qu'il comprendraiit
parfaitement la transformation de notre
économie en une économie de guerre ça
veut dire réquisition d'entreprise
civile ça veut dire formation pour
l'industrie militaire d'un certain
nombre de travailleurs français ça veut
dire aussi ça a été proposé par d'autres
que par moi je soutiens tout à fait
cette idée un grand emprunt pour
l'Ukraine moi j'y souscris demain bien
sûr euh je je pense que vraiment nous
devons voir français au niveau européen
alors je pense qu'au niveau français
pour des raisons opérationnelles c'est
beaucoup plus facile à gérer maintenant
s'il y a des proposition technique qui
dit c'est au niveau européen très bien
aussi hein l'essentiel c'est de faire en
sorte que chaque citoyen de l'Europe est
vraiment la conscience que c'est sa vie
et surtout le destin de ses enfants qui
est en jeu c'estàdire que c'est un
destin en fait nous sommes à un moment
si vous voulez qui est un moment 1939 ou
1941 véritablement toutes chos égal par
ailleurs où nous devommes devant quelque
chose qui ressemble véritablement quand
on voit le type de massacre les tortures
organisé planifié destruction de de
personnes assassinat civil qui on est
devant le mal absolu je le dis très
clairement et nous devons comprendre la
nature de cette guerre totale ce n'est
pas une guerre classique si vous voulez
au sens de guerre territoriale c'est une
guerre absolue une guerre
d'anéantissement de l'Ukraine donc si
nous comprenons cela et bien je pense
que nous devons encore une fois nous
mobiliser quand uel Macron dit nous ne
pouvons pas laisser la Russie gagner
c'est ce qu'il a répété encore il y a
quelques jours est-ce que vous pensez là
aussi que tous les Européens sont unis
sur cet objectif alors je pense que la
plupart sont unis sauf la Hongrie sauf
peut-être la Slovaquie enfin je parle du
gouvernement je parle pas des citoyens
Slovaques je pense que encore une fois
les peuples européens le comprennent je
pense aussi et je je dirais plutôt que
de faire une négation comme le fait le
président de la République je dirais
plutôt il faut que l'Ukraine gagne et
que la Russie perde donc il faut qu'il
ait des mots plus clairs pour je enfin
je pense que voilà c'est là c'est une
négation il faut pas que la Russie moi
je dirais non il faut que la Russie
perde et je pense qu'il faut vraiment le
formuler dans ces termes et que nous
devons dire que notre objectif j'oserais
dire notre but de guerre et bien que la
Russie perde et qu'elle perde soyons
parfaitement clair qu'elle perde en
Ukraine mais aussi qu'elle perde en
geéorgie 20 % du territoire occupé par
la Russie qu'elle perd au Bélarus vous
avez le dictateur lukashenka qui est
dans la main de la Russie qu'elle perd
dans les pays africains qui sont mis en
coupe réglé pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux par la Russie et par des
milices russes on le sait qu'ell perd en
Birmanie où la Russie avec la Chine
soutient la jeune birmane et qu'elle
perde aussi dans son son soutien à des
mouvements terroristes ou des pays
terroristes comme l'Iran ou la Corée du
Nord et donc je quand je dis moment 39
ou 41 c'est aussi pour que le 1945 que
demain nous connaîtrons ce soit un 45
qui soit celui de la victoire comme la
victoire des Alliés et pas celui d'une
défaite mais est-ce que les les
dirigeants sont trop timorés vous posez
cette question dans votre livre que vous
une dissuasion sans volonté
d'intervention exactement et je pense
que c'est un des vrais sujets
c'est-à-dire que sur l'OTAN et en
particulier la dissuasion nucléaire nous
avons considéré pendant longtemps que
elle suffisait cette dissuasion
nucléaire c'est c'est le ce qui est
implicitement derrière la article 5 ceon
appelle les garanties de sécurité du
Traité de Washington donc qui régit l'ut
temp en fait le vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c'est la garantie la dissuision pardon
conventionnelle c'estàdire il faut que
les troupes de l'OTAN soient capable de
se dire nous allons attaquer le cas
échéant où nous sommes prêts à le faire
un adversaire sur le sol européen soit
le sol des pays de l'OTAN la plupart des
pays de l'Europe de fait ils sont soit
même aux frontières de l'OTAN
parce que nous avons un paystiers qui
menace en attaquant un pays tiers comme
la Russie comme la l'Ukraine ou comme la
Géorgie qui menace notre propre sécurité
et je pense que nous devons penser aussi
sur le plan de l'organisation de nos
forces de défense en France et en Europe
à quelque chose comme une défense
territoriale européenne c'estàd qu'on n
plus les forces d'intervention si vous
voulez avant c'était surtout pour
intervenir à l'extérieur c'était le cas
aussi pour le Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui il
faut vraiment déplacer ce concept
d'intervention vers le centre de
l'Europe euh il y a vous nous parliez
tout à l'heure de la question du temps
et vous nous disiez le temps joue contre
l'Ukraine est-ce que l'Ukraine peut
encore gagner cette guerre selon vous
oui bien sûr moi je pense que l'Ukraine
peut gagner je pense d'abord que le
discours du défétisme c'est un discours
qui est très favorisé euh par la
propagande du créelin il y a tout un
chapitre dans ce livre où j'évoque ce
que j'appelle la propagande douce
c'est-à-dire que vous c'est pas
uniquement les vous savez les trucs
grossier du genre il y a des nazis àives
euh bon ça c'est c'est grossier la
plupart des gens censé évidemment n'y
croi pas mais tout le petit discours
mais l'Ukraine ne peut pas gagner tout
le conflit se termine par une
négociation finalement il faudra bien
des concessions
territoriales et finalement il faudra
bien un jour s'asseoir à avec la Russie
tout ce discours là c'est un discours de
propagande du kremelin et
malheureusement il est repris ou il a
été repris très longtemps par un certain
nombre de personnages politiques de
dirigeants même français allemands
américains et c'est ça
qui estce qu'il va falloir négcier avec
Vladimir Poutin alors premièrement
premièrement oui la Russie peut gagner
mais ça dépend de nous c'estàdire que ça
dépend pas uniquement de l'Ukraine ça
dépend de nos forces c'est-à-dire ça
dépend de la résolution que nous aurons
à armer l'Ukraine jusqu'au bout voir si
possible et je le souhaite et je pense
que c'est nécessaire d'intervenir
directement pour frapper à un moment
donné les troupes russes stationnés en
Ukraine ou qui attaquent l'Ukraine je
pense que ça il faudra vraiment le
formuler dans ces termes là c'est le
terme de la victoire donc elle est
possible militairement elle est possible
il y a absolument aucune raison et on
voit d'ailleurs que même moi ça m'a
frappé chaque fois que je suis allé
encore en Ukraine pendant cette guerre
de voir l'ingéniosité l'agilité
intellectuelle extraordinaire des
Ukrainiens et notamment des militaires
Ukrainiens qui vont être capable dans
les années qui viennent d'ailleurs de
bâtir une défense eux-même avec une une
inventivité une capacité je crois que
l'autonomie stratégique dont beaucoup
parlent pour l'Europe je pense que les
Ukrainiens vont le faire donc
premièrement oui ils vont gagner de
est-ce qu'on peut négocier avec Vladimir
Poutine la réponse est NON je me
rappelle j'avais fait en février écrit
en février 2016 un article on ne peut
pas négocier avec la Russie de Poutine
je suis sur cette position premièrement
parce que le droit international ne se
négocie pas est-ce qu'on peut négocier
l'intégrité des frontières tous les
dirigeants européens et compris le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron disent clairement ben il y a
l'intégrité territoriale c'est un
principe sacré on peut pas négocier
là-dessus que deuxièmement tant que vous
allez avoir une partie du territoire
ukrainien occupé par les Russes
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
déportation dans enfant ce qui est un
crime de génocide en vertu de la
Convention du 9 décembre 1948 ça voudra
dire torture on a vu les chambres de
torture à Kerson et ailleurs ça voudra
dire assassinat de civil sans fin on
peut pas accepter ça négocier en plus
avec un état qui a Manti jusqu'au début
je trouve que hier je ressortais par
hasard un tweet d'une ambassade qui
reprenait les discours de laavrov du 18
février 2022 et qui disait mais l'idée
que la Russie va attaquer l'Ukraine tout
ça c'est de la propagande des États-Unis
bon donc on sait très bien ce qui s'est
passé 6 jours après donc on peut pas la
Russie a violé il y a quelqu'un qui a
fait la liste une centaine de traités
internationaux euh ensuite qu'est-ce que
ça voudrait dire négocier ça voudrait
dire que la Russie va se réarmer va
continuer à attaquer ou va se remettre à
attaquer 1 an 2 ans 3 ans après non la
Russie doit être défaite militairement
alors je suis pas en train de dire qu'il
faut envoyer des troupes européennes ou
américaines à Moscou bien sûr que non
mais ça veut dire que l'ensemble des
troupes russes doivent quitter l'Ukraine
que nous devons maintenir pendant très
longtemps et j'ai tout un chapitre sur
Russie pour sur l'évolution de la Russie
c'est parce que derrière vous avez aussi
l'idée de comment faire en sorte que
l'évolution de la Russie se dessine et
que le peuple russe devienne libre nous
devons maintenir l'ensemble des
sanctions jusqu'au bout et dernier point
si vous me le permettez il faut
absolument que l'ensemble des crimes
commis par la Russie crime de guerre
crime contre l'humanité crime de
génocide et crime d'agression tous les
quatre
imprescriptible parfaitement documenté
il faut que les auteurs de ces crimes
soient punis et qu'il y ait un moment
quelque chose comme un sens de la
culpabilité
collective qui
imprègne je pense l'esprit les
consciences des citoyens russes comme ça
s'est passé et je reprends le terme de
culpabilité cullective de Carl JASP du
philosophe qui disait exactement la même
chose pour l'Allemagne après le nazisme
même si tous les Russes ne sont pas
coupables ceux qui le sont physiquement
devront être jugés je crois qu'il y a un
moment où ils devront prendre conscience
de ce crime et il faudra qu'il y ait un
jour des mémoriaux sur la place ruse aux
victimes du poutinisme comme aux
victimes du stalinisme et qui est cette
compréhension et ça aussi c'est
absolument essentiel pour que l'histoire
devienne un jour une histoire plus
heureuse vous n parliez des États-Unis
il y a des élections présidentielles
cette année aux États-Unis Donald Trump
est le son camp on l'a vu il a remporté
la la première des primaires
républicaines dans l'aiowa Qu'est-ce
qu'une possible potentielle victoire de
Trump changerait d'abord oui bien sûr
parce qu'on sait très bien que Trump est
totalement corrompu par l'argent russe
soit lui directement soit son entourage
que il n'aurait aucun problème à
sacrifier une partie du territoire
ukrainien il avait dit lorsqu'il était
Président que l'OT temp était obsolète
donc on peut pas du tout exclure que
soit il quitte l'OT temp soit qu'il
liminue ensemble des financements à
l'OTAN ce qui serait un peu près la même
chose donc et que les États-Unis ne
soutiennent plus l'Ukraine voilà et et
là c'est un vrai problème parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand même la
moitié des armements et aussi des
financements parce que derrière le
financement pour que le pays puisse
fonctionner donc payer les
fonctionnaires payer les militaires
payer les infrastructures qu'est-ce que
ça voudrait dire pour l'Ukraine si les
États-Unis partaient et surtout que
l'Europe aujourd'hui n'est pas capable
on le sait de remplacer les États-Unis
euh je pense que là-dessus d'ailleurs
l'intuition d'Emmanuel Macron était
juste même s'il avait très très mal
exprimé pour dest raisons sur non pas
seulement sur l'OTAN sur vous savez
l'autonomie la question de de ce qu'on
appelait l'autonomie stratégique de
l'Europe c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui si
nous n'avons pas les
États-Unis l'Europe ne peut pas décider
par elle-même plutôt n'a pas les moyens
euh d'intervenir pour défendre une
nation alliée
agressée un peu cette semaine il a
appelé l'Europe à se réarmer ah il faut
il faut et je pense qu'il faut le faire
que nous devons d'ailleurs montrer
l'exemple on le montre pas encore
suffisamment mais enfin on va dans la
bonne direction bien sûr il faut il faut
absolument se réarmer mais même dans ces
situations là si demain effectivement on
a un Trump qui dit voilà on est plus
l'Ukraine ça va être extraordinairement
difficile il faut savoir que si nous
devions alors aussi en terme de de je
sera un peu un peu compliqué de
l'exposer en détail rapidement mais
aussi en terme de de de dissuasion
nucléaire si nous devions un jour
remplacer les États-Unis sur ce planl il
faudrait porter le budget de la Défense
des pays européens à 6 ou 7 % du PIB euh
donc aujourd'hui déjà il y a un objectif
de 2 % qui est affiché il est pas atint
on est 1 et dem aujourhui certains pays
vont plus loin hein vous le savez les
pays baltes la Pologne et cetera mais en
même temps puisque on retour on retourne
à cela c'est pour ça aussi que je pense
et c'est quelque chose dis régulièrement
à ce que je connais dans
l'administration Biden nous devons aussi
aller plus vite plus loin il y a une
très bonne étude du ministère estonien
de la défense qui montrait qu'avec 0 25
% du PIB consacré au soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine des pays de l'Alliance nous
pouvions l'emporter et ça c'est quelque
chose que nous pouvons faire on parlait
de la possible victoire de de Trump aux
États-Unis il y a aussi des élections
européennes ici le 9 juin prochain du 5
au 9 juin prochain dans les pays de
l'Union européenne est-ce que vous
redoutez une montée des populistes au
sein de l'Union européenne alors moi je
je je je l'expression populiste j'ai
tout un chapitre sur le populisme dans
mon livre donc je définition est assez
compliquée mais je crain la monté de
l'extrême droite je préfère l'utiliser
l'appeler comme ça oui l'extrême droite
ou plus généralement des partis
antiystème ce qui inclut d'ailleurs une
grande partie de l'extrême gauche oui
c'est-à-dire que ce sont des partis
d'abord qui ne soutiennent pas les
démocraties qui se moquent des
violations des droits de l'homme qui
sont prêts à s'alliier ou à être financé
le cas échéant par des régimes
dictatoriaux et criminels et si
effectivement ils deviennent trop fort
au sein du Parlement européen ça veut
dire aussi que le vote euh de soutien du
budget concrètement consacré à la
défense de l'Europe et à l'Ukraine
risque d'être diminué ou beaucoup plus
difficile à voter donc il y a oui il y a
un vrai risque vous avez eu quand même
indépendamment du vote beaucoup de
résolutions très du Parlement européen
qui ont dénoncé des pratiques des
dictatures pas uniquement d'ailleurs la
Russie mais aussi la Chine hein quand
même des des résolutions très dure sur
le Shing Chang qui ont refusé d'avoir
cet accord honteux qui avait été forgé à
l'époque par Angela Merkel accord
d'investissement avec la Chine populaire
et qui ont voté contre donc je pense
qu'il est très important d'avoir
effectivement des majorités
démocratiques libérales euh pour en
faveur de la société ouverte au
Parlement européen donc il y a une vraie
menace et il y a une vraie mobilisation
à avoir
un mot sur ce qui se passe en Israël
hier Benjamin nanahou a dit que la
victoire prendra de longs mois et qu'il
ne se satisfera pas moins d'une qu'une
victoire totale est-ce qu'elle est
possible cette victoire totale victoire
totale pour lui c'estentissement du
Hamas alors je pense surtout d'abord
premièrement il faut pas faire de
parallèle entre ce qui se passe en
Israël et ce qui se passe en
Ukraine nous sommes avec l'Ukraine
devant une guerre
existentielle je pense qu'en Israël nous
avons eu les acte de génocide perpétré
par le Hamas mais le Hamas aussi
abominable soit-il c'est un groupe
terroriste encore une fois qui a commis
un génocide c'est parfaitement évident
et bien ce n'est pas un danger
existentiel pour l'existence d'Israël
non plus que deuxièmement je pense que
nous n'avons pas intérêt à avoir une
guerre longue comme le souhaite Nou pour
se maintenir au pouvoir il n y a pas
d'autres raison et que nous avons plutôt
intérêt nous occidentaux à avoir une
guerre courte je pense qu'il n'y aura
pas d'aut autre voie aussi bien je
disais avec la Russie on ne peut pas
négocier je pense je parle pas du Hamas
le Hamas il doit être balayé on est
parfaitement clair là-dessus mais je
pense que il faudra bien qu'il y ait une
négociation entre Israël et la Palestine
il faudra parvenir à une solution à deux
états et ce qui est absolument
nécessaire aujourd'hui c'est que les
États-Unis qui sont beaucoup plus forts
que l'Europe qui est très divisé
malheureusement sur cette question
s'engage sur le long terme et là je n'en
suis pas sûr qu'il y ait ou non victoire
de Trump d'ailleurs hein soyons
parfaitement clair là-dessus il faut que
les Anglais les États-Unis s'engagent
sur le long terme comme il l'avait fait
par le passé avec com davit avec les
accords deos slow pour obtenir une
négociation entre les deux parties ça
prendra beaucoup de temps les inceurs de
part et d'autes d'ailleurs sont un peu
difficiles à trouver on le sait très
bien mais je pense surtout qu'il ne faut
pas qu'il y ait de guerre longue il faut
être parfaitement clair sur la
dénonciation des actes terroristes du
Hamas leur condamnation n'est pas
négociable elle est absolue mais il faut
aussi
qu'Israël soit doit absolument
exemplaire dans son comportement et
aujourd'hui il y a quand même de forts
soupçons de crimes de guerre je dis pas
CRIM de génocide mais de CRIM de guerre
commis parce que tout simplement il y a
une disproportion dans l'utilisation des
moyens et ce n'est pas acceptable et ça
devient très dangereux parce que don du
coup ça donne un argument sur lequel
joue Vladimir Poutine à l'égard des pays
du Sud c'est l'argument appppelle
parfois le wataboutisme c'estàd que
quand on dit crime de la Russie on dit
oui mais enfin vous voyez il y a des
crimes c'est pas du tout la même chose
bien sûr le contexte différent mais je
pense qu'on a vraiment besoin
aujourd'hui c'est toutes les
perspectives que je dessine à un moment
dans le livre d'ailleurs de
rétablissement d'un ordre fondé sur le
droit international et ça nous avons
besoin de cohérence absolue merci
Nicolas Tanzer merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité on revoit votre livre
notre guerre le crime et l'oubli pour
une pensée stratégique c'est aux
éditions de l'Observatoire merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité on
passe au club de territoire